et andreas et donc aller dans la rue
pour savoir si les français étaient
plutôt booba ou caris voilà c'est notre
petit macoutes du jour vous allez voir
que peu importe qu'ils soutiennent
bon c'est facile de leur faire changer
d'avis comme d'habitude regarde bonjour
comment tu t'appelles tableau ce que tu
écoutes un peu de rap français
j'ai beaucoup entendu parler du combat
qui aura lieu entre mumbai charisme
octogone tout ça du coup toi tu soutiens
qui a un pouvoir car les escaliers parce
que booba et prend le trou était plutôt
boubakary on est dite prête au vainqueur
mais sinon en rapidité dite prête au
hockey je crois qu'on ne s'est pas
compris ok comme banques à risque
carrez sur un mec de 9,3 donc c'est plus
qu'un risque pour quoi bon bah c'est pas
ton prêt à y raconte un peu trop de
maintenance yeux car il va le démonter
ok d'accord on va en fait je t'explique
on aurait pu gagner deux places pour
aller au combat
boubacar et non en vip avec chicha et
champagne à volonté
malheureusement révélé que ceux qui
soutiennent la move arc c'est vrai vite
fait un peu défaut ces moulages veut pas
de faire les contre-propositions
développement ça restera toujours le
meilleur c'est le coin le duc by car ici
safran qui va gagner
[Musique]
booba charice dozos il va gagner car il
serait qu'il allait un peu plus petit
costaud droit pas de faire la paix de
faire gagner deux places pour aller au
combat coincé malheureusement mais
malheureusement il ya pour clarisse
du coup tu es plutôt glauque avec booba
alors pourquoi pas car ici parce qu'il
est petit justement voilà un coup de
genou dans les dom voilà c'est fini tu
soutiens booba ouais ok plutôt martin
niveau du radar non c'est pas cool on
peut gagner que ceux qui soutiennent ces
questions car il joue bien je devais
aller contre été confirmée carriço au
nom car il s'écoule aussi qui arrivent
car il fait du bon son il fait du bon
sens
on a un beau gars s'est terminée sakaris
et nouvel air du coup tu connais un
petit morceau de carrie statut pour nous
enchanter nos frères ne peut pas c'est
pour les places tout d'abord ta mère la
grosse non c'est bon c'est mon premier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
super